but why is it important to you to try to
see if you can do these things I think
I'm always questing to be better like I
think I wanna
I wanna get the best out of myself and I
feel like right now it's through these
kind of big ridiculous challenges I want
to showcase for people that it is
possible like I I didn't come from a big
endurance background I didn't know any
of these things when I first started
like I started like so many other people
with like a little goal and then from
there I was like maybe I can do
something else at the base levels I want
to see if I can do it I want to see if
it's possible for me I hope when people
see me now they're like well if that
dude with like you know all these other
commitments can do it like maybe I can
do it too